welcome back robin from your travels
robin was tweeting
facebooking text i knew she was having a
bad time when i saw that every single
minute robin was facebooking and texting
well there was a lot of time on the bus
going from place to place and a lot of
boring stuff you were up to god i was
like god i just kept thinking the whole
time
what a waste of a week's vacation oh my
god like you did something so exciting
no i relaxed i enjoyed myself i was out
with mayan people
you know what's great though robin went
on a u.n fact-finding mission and i
guarantee you found out nothing i did i
found out
what are you talking about
i found out something i feel like
oh stop it you call everything away it
was so incredible
guatemala is beautiful robin's facebook
was like that i'm now in the coffee
coffee farm coffee farm
coffee plantation and then like a minute
later it was like still at the coffee
farm
does anybody have a copy of robin's
tweets and facebook postings
you gotta hear what's going on with this
it's nice that the dollar still means
something in some part of the world
well i mean have you you haven't been to
europe where it means nothing what's
this big duck duck goose thing you
played duck duck goose sweet children in
guatemala yeah we went to a school or an
after-school program actually for
guatemalan girls duck goose is a
demanding game i forgot we were at
4 000 feet above sea level almost died
trying to run around that circle and
after robin played with the kids we were
a hit
the young ones asked us to join their
play group and even the older kids came
out to watch us play they probably were
like what the [ __ ]
girls i'm a vegan we are going to play
carrot carrot cucumber instead of duck
goose
they are teaching you an inappropriate
game
look at this tweet i need a nap from a
too heavy lunch beans beans beans
[Music]
good for the heart
guatemala is known for coffee nice to
see how the ingredient for my enemas has
grown
that's that's a funny tweet
how many people followed your tweets i
don't know i didn't even know you
tweeted i didn't know how many i
couldn't get on the internet very often
i was just doing that by my blackberry
well thank god i felt connected
i wanted you to know at every moment
beth and i kept vlogging i was okay
i said where's robin now
she's still on the bus
oh man good for you robin can triumphant
as usual and there you are